can you see my shirt hey honey
she's rioting she's pissed down with
Weight Watchers hey everyone i'm abby
sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen so I had
another video plan for today but then
this super nasty ass bombshell literally
shook my world and has been keeping me
up at night so I move things around yes
today we're going to be talking about
wws new kirbo app I am pissed so here's
the deal ww formerly known as Weight
Watchers but you know they're all about
wellness now just launched their new
weight-loss app for kids between the
ages of 8 and 17 the app promises to
help our little ones meet their goals
like lose weight boost confidence and
the most cringeworthy make your parents
happy I'm sorry but if watching your
child develop a life-threatening eating
disorder just ruin their amazing
intuition around food and set off on a
life long struggle around food in their
body makes you happy as a parent I think
it's time to re-evaluate your role now I
want to take it back for a second and
say that as a fellow parent I can
absolutely empathize with parents who
really want to do whatever it is that
they can tell their kids live their
healthiest happiest life we do know that
research suggests that that kids are
more likely to be bullied both verbally
and physically at school what's even
more devastating is that these kids tend
to have even lower levels of self esteem
which in turn can lead to feelings of
loneliness sadness and even diagnose
depression now only does this play a
role in their personal relationships but
this can also play a role in their sleep
psychological stress levels and academic
performance
so during an already stressful and
vulnerable age I feel like these kids
already have a lot to deal with and if
encouraging your kids to eat fewer chips
or just running around the block a few
times could save them from all of this I
can see the appeal however here's the
thing
your help may actually do more harm than
good in today's video I hope to shed
some light on what you should be way
more concerned about apps like this and
dieting in general then your kid gaining
some weight during puberty let's take a
look at some of the reasons why you
should boycott this app today number one
food cannot be categorized into good
food bad food and okay sometimes food so
kirbo uses a traffic light system
categorizing foods as green light a k
good and free and you can eat when you
want yellow light as in sometimes foods
and red light aka the bad foods and the
fun thing is they encourage kids to
track every bite
ww has described this app as a holistic
tool not a diet but what it really is is
a more preschool friendly version of
calorie counting or an offshoot of their
popular point system in fact I would
argue that categorizing food into three
distinct categories is way more damaging
than calorie counting or points counting
while teaching kids nothing at all about
nutrition kids are really [ __ ] smart
if they log in that they ate almond
butter which is a really nutrient dense
food in my opinion as a dietitian and
mom and see that they got a red stripe
they're never gonna eat almond butter
again and then we have a whole
generation of kids who are afraid of
almond butter on the flip side seeing
foods as bad has the power to make kids
want them even more research suggests
that foods we associate with guilt like
chocolate cake are more difficult to
resist overeating do we really need to
have kids binging not only on cake but
almond butter in secret
hell no number two the nutrition
recommendations themselves are bullish
now this is a bit of a moot point
because like I said before we should not
be categorizing foods as good food bad
food and kind of bad food but I'm legit
so confused about what the criteria was
for these categories under the traffic
light system
my son's breakfast a full fat plain
Greek yogurt with some banana on top and
a slice of sourdough bread with some
almond butter would rack up a whopping 3
red strikes what the actual I don't know
about you but that is a really
nutrient-dense mule in my books and I
would be so proud as a mom to see my son
gobble that whole thing up and then ask
for seconds but nope WW kirbo app is
teaching our kids to fear any food that
is not that free salt free flavor free
and calorie free let's be real this is a
calorie game number three dieting
increases eating disorder risk in
children the words diet and children
should really never be going together
and the research does confirm to us why
this is so first of all in general diets
don't work you know you hear me say this
all the time but the research suggests
that 90 to 95 percent of people will
regain that way right back it's just not
sustainable
the same goes for children in a 2017
Cochrane review researchers found that
weight loss interventions in children
between the ages of 5 and 11 did result
in some modest weight loss none of it
was maintainable long term in addition
the researchers found that a lot of
these studies that did have weight loss
success with their children and their
weight loss interventions had major
study flaws yet kirbo uses a lot of
these same studies to cite evidence in
support of their program big fail what
kirbo fails to mention is that what
dieting does is lock people into a
lifetime of weight cycling also known as
yo-yo dieting the research suggests that
going up and down and up and down your
weight is way more dangerous and
detrimental to your health than just
always kind of maintaining a higher BMI
in fact this type of high stress on your
body has been shown to increase your
risk of high blood pressure inflammation
and even early death not only that but
weight cycling can also be really
emotionally stressful as well it's that
constant battle and give-and-take
between feeling kind of ashamed of your
body and food choices that temporarily
kind of feeling a satisfaction when you
finally lose a few pounds and then that
overwhelming guilt and shame that comes
when inevitably you gain that way back
furthermore research suggests that
children who are big
of weight stigma are more likely to
avoid just basic healthy behaviors like
exercise which in turn can perpetuate
any of that weight gain since kirbo
blatantly stigmatizes people at bigger
bodies and automatically suggest weight
loss as secure kids are bound to feel
badly about themselves and potentially
could turn to dangerous coping
mechanisms like substance abuse
disengagement and weight cycling most
problematically is that children and
adults who go on diets are at higher
risk of developing an eating disorder
not only does this interfere with our
innate body wisdom our ability to kind
of hone in on our hunger and satiety
cues but heavily restricting calories is
bound to be followed by a binge when we
inevitably slip up so we engage in this
restrict binge repent repeat cycle that
literally goes on for life early dieters
tend to have higher risks of eating
disorder behaviors like severely
restricting calories excessive exercise
vomiting using laxatives and other diet
pills
yeah our society applauds these dieting
behaviors as virtuous while turning a
blind eye to these life-threatening
behaviors and when I say
life-threatening I mean it eating
disorders have the highest mortality
rates of all mental health disorders
even depression wake up
kirbo is the gateway drug to this all
number for preteens and teens need to
gain weight and fat you know our society
is so fat phobic when we are terrified
of our children gaining weight in a way
that is imperative to their health and
well-being first of all the way that our
body processes and holds onto fat is
largely genetic some people will gain
more fat than others even if the eating
environment is the exact same some
people have more fat in their bum mat
some people have it in their legs some
people have store it in their bellies
we're all so different
so considering that we can appreciate
that we all have a different genetic
makeup the same way that we have
different color hair different colored
eyes I don't understand why we cannot
really wrap our head around the idea of
us also just having a different body
composition
well despite our society's overwhelming
fear of fat it's actually really
important body fat is so key for keeping
our organs protected temperature
regulation cell signaling and hormone
regulation just to name a few perks in
children body fat plays a really
important role in growth and development
so during puberty fat actually signals
the development of a lot of our sex
hormones like testosterone for boys and
estrogen progesterone for girls which in
turn play a role in you know getting
taller breast development menstruation
body hair etc in girls having sufficient
fat stores is really important to
helping to develop and maintain a
healthy menstrual cycle if that stores
get too low in nutrients stores in
general are insufficient this can stunt
sexual maturation unfortunately a lot of
young girls who try to stunt their
natural weight gain our risk of delayed
period and it may take a long time to
resume normal growth body size and shape
are like eye color we are all so
different and we would never shame our
child for having brown eyes or try to
will them into trying to make them blue
it is so cruel to me that any parent
want to change their eight-year-old
child especially when we know the risks
of doing so and that those changes are
temporary at best number five the kirbo
app promotes fat phobia I think one of
the most disturbing parts of the kirbo
app are the before-and-after photos of
these young children and the success
stories which honestly are creepy as and
just really sad to read Vanessa is eight
years old and has lost 11 BMI points and
her mom says that watching Vanessa say
no to unhealthy foods that she otherwise
and previously would never have said no
to before has really surprised her I'm
amazed at Vanessa's willpower and
motivation let that one sink in whoa dye
culture makes us believe that in order
to change our body it just comes down to
a little bit of simple willpower but the
reality is that for that poor little
girl she's probably five
being so hard and falling so deep into
disorderly thoughts that she doesn't
even know how to trust her body or food
anymore
number six wave stigma and weight
cycling is a much bigger problem than
weight itself now if you're standing
there and thinking oh well it's just for
their health we want to do it to better
their health let me tell you that is
both and the research makes it clear in
fact all of your dieting efforts will
just have a really negative impact on
their health pressure to lose weight and
achieve unrealistic beauty standards is
not going to help a person achieve good
health in fact research suggests that
weight is not associated with mortality
as much as Fitness's regardless of how
much that fitness or can activity level
increases or decreases a person's weight
the same is true for diet a
meta-analysis of the research found that
dietary interventions like increasing
fiber or following a more of like a
Mediterranean style diet was associated
with reducing the risk of diabetes as
well as improving blood cholesterol
blood sugar and blood pressure levels
even if it did not impact the person's
weight meanwhile when a person
experiences weight stigma which is
judgment around their size they're much
more likely to engage in unhealthy
eating behaviors avoid seeing a doctor
and disengage from social behaviors and
activities in contrast when people feel
confident in their body they're much
more likely to engage in healthy
lifestyle behaviors and feel in control
of their health regardless of their size
or weight in a systematic review
researchers found that interventions
that focus more on health behaviors like
healthy eating intuitive eating physical
activity were much more likely to impact
health outcomes like reducing the risk
of heart disease and depression
meanwhile diets and interventions that
focused on restriction or body weight
showed little to no improvements on
health so what does this all mean it
means that we need to focus on our
behaviors not our weight and not our
size when it comes to promoting health
and number seven diets just don't thing
work my morning email from my kirbo app
told me that 90% of kids using the kirbo
coach system
we'll lose weight within three months an
upgrade that will cost you $69 per month
but what they don't tell us is how
quickly these kids are going to gain all
that way back and then some weight loss
companies love to show before-and-after
photos but what they don't show us is
follow-up photos a few months or even
years later what we know is that sure
it's pretty easy to lose some pounds on
a crash diet but 90 to 95 percent of
people will gain that weight back and
usually even more so within months or
years later just take a look at the
Biggest Loser as an example one 2016
study found that participants gained
almost all of the weight back and their
metabolisms got so up that they were
eating less calories but still creeping
back up to their original weights even
Oprah who is a paid ambassador of Weight
Watchers program cannot seem to maintain
her weight loss on the program at
different stages in her life while many
people go on diets to improve their
health the research consistently shows
us that they're just not the solution it
can often do a lot more harm than good
so with all that said what should we be
doing instead look I totally understand
the concern around our children's health
I'm a mom too
but we really need to be focusing on
sustainable long term behaviors that
promote a healthy relationship with food
and body image if the research has told
us anything is that diets do not work
and they do not belong anywhere near our
children so number one instead of
restricting food and vilifying it lets
work with our kids to develop their
intuitive eating skills we need to get
rid of the moral judgment and the
dichotomies around good food and bad
food and really work towards using more
neutral language so for example instead
of saying eat your broccoli it's good
for you
why don't you say we love broccoli it's
so delicious and it helps us grow number
two you have to model a healthy
relationship with food never associate
certain foods with your body or your
worth so avoid using phrases like oh my
god I beans so bad I shouldn't have the
cake or I'm just too fat as it is to eat
pie these statements not only perpetuate
weight stigma and fat
phobia but they also teach our kids that
our worth is derived from the food that
we eat
so instead try talking about fun food as
being pleasurable so for example saying
grandma baked this cake or pie with so
much love I'm sure it's going to be
delicious
let's enjoy it together as a family
number three I also recommend teaching
our kids to appreciate all the amazing
things that our bodies can do running
and lifting and jumping and climbing
this helps show our kids that their
bodies regardless of their size or shape
are capable of doing amazing things
finally we want to lead by example and
denounce diet culture it's really
important that we never criticize our
body their body or anybody else's bodies
we want to teach our kids that bodies
come in all different sizes and shapes
research suggests that when a parent
openly discusses their dissatisfaction
with their own body the child is more
likely to die in the future we need to
breed a new generation of children and
eventual adults who love and respect all
bodies regardless of size or shape not
ones who loathe and fear their bodies
when they eventually no longer maintain
a size two okay let's call it kirbo for
what it really is a money-hungry attempt
to hook customers for life with fat
phobia and disordered eating behaviors
and thoughts the best predictor of
weight gain is dieting so that coupled
with weight stigma weight cycling and
disordered eating that go hand in hand
with diets this app has the real
potential to turn an on problem into a
real problem really fast
if ww-was actually interested in
improving our children's health it's
coaching would not be set at a premium
price or only the wealthy have access to
it it wouldn't promote a lifetime of
dieting it wouldn't be calling almond
butter unhealthy and it wouldn't be
teaching our children that there's
inherently something wrong with their
body
wake up Weight Watchers please pull this
app off the market today so everybody if
this all sounds familiar to you and
Weight Watchers was kind of the hook
that dragged you into a lifetime of diet
culture and dieting and weight cycling
if you feel so inclined I would love
to hear from you in the comments section
below I know this is a very sensitive
topic but also a real relatable topic I
hear this from so many people so please
feel free to share as always like this
video subscribe to the channel share the
out of it because we need to take this
down and on that note I will see you
next time on Abby's kitchen thanks so
much bye
[Music]